I am with the incredible and net betting
I'm so thrilled to talk to you today
thank you what was it about this project
that really attracted you to it because
you've done so many different kinds of
films oh just the chance to get to work
on a Marvel movie I was so excited at
the prospect of it the idea of it and
then when I read it I thought this is
cool I get to do some really fun stuff
and it has proved to be a joy
what is it that you look for in a
character when you like maybe I'll take
that role with where there's certain
things in this that you're like yeah
that crosses some T's and dot some eyes
well I get to do more than one thing
there's a duality to what I do so in
some ways you think I'm kind of one
thing but I'm actually another thing
part of what I do is I get to play the
supreme intelligence and within that
there's a lot of creativity let's say
I'm sure a lot of people who know the
Marvel world know who that is or what
that is but in an our story the way
that's the supreme intelligence is
embodied is new what does it meant to
you personally to get to be part of the
first female lead solo Marvel film well
super fun it's brie Larson who's a great
actress and someone that I had met
before and I knew she would be terrific
two great directors Ryan and Anna who
are approaching it with their own you
know sensibility their own sense of
story and sense of humor and all of that
but yeah the fact that you know women
are stepping up and taking charge and
taking charge of the universe that's
definitely a good thing women in charge
of the universe I'm here for it I got me
to me now what are you hoping fans come
away feeling when they see this film
ultimately all these movies have great
fun it's great fun it's a great
adventure there's a lot of humor there's
a lot of you know wit in the movie
that's what I've always loved about
these movies is they have such a great
sense of humor but at the core there's a
real hero's story
go see Marvel Studios Captain Marvel in
theaters now